muté ou moment il faut couper là
[Musique]
nous amène aujourd'hui à paris on va
face de l'hôtel hilton on va pour la
présentation de rimini qui arrive en
frontal j'ai pas si vous connaissez le
mic travailler avec au pot était une
boîte qui appartenait au bronze lui ce
sont deux entités différentes et lancent
leur premier smartphone en france
leur slogan ses proches tout billon
fiers notre job plutôt cool j'ai testé
le readme de l'année dernière c'est un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme
on va voir ce qu'il nous concocte un
oeil ça peut être assez intéressant
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
parlons un peu de ce smartphone sur une
nuit plutôt pas mal qui passe comment
vous trouvez vous le 3 pro le design est
sympa vous retrouver ici un capteur
d'empreintes digitales un dos plastique
assez standard plusieurs effet vous avez
82 lits sais pas si vous les voyez bien
un peu compliqué il a 82 ans line
différentes double module photo un
bouton pour l'allumer pour les fans de
ce côté microsd haut parleurs monoprix
jack sur le côté goûtons de volume
lecteur de carte sim ou micro traduction
bruit micro plutôt pas mal
les gens pensent intéressant sur le
papier qualité prix ouais et c'est tout
ne voulait pas trop non mais après ce
que vous en pensez mais il ya eu
l'appareil photo il a droit tu peux le
dire trois rennais là il est le premier
surtout chez une grosse batterie ça
c'est une pavane 4040 donc qu'elles ont
avec la charger abidal
3 ok mais pourquoi vous trois nous
pouvons nous trouver
[Musique]
était là pour le duel avec deux là mais
commence a dormi pendant la prière voilà
la réputation que j'étais resté chez lui
qu il ya trois ans fait déjà mais déjà
mais rentrer c'est facile victoire est
celle ci n'a jamais glané vaillant parce
que là on peut pas le dire je n'étais
pas là dans ces moments il faut couper
alors deux smartphones alors on vient de
finir la presse on coule on a donc deux
couleurs couleur là un peu côté violine
ça c'est plus
purple sympa lequel vous préférez marqué
le manga en commentaire donc produit que
je trouve sur le papier en tout cas
c'est sympa mais je pense qu'il est
difficile un pari je me sois d'allemagne
avec moi ce qui va être difficile pour
la marque c'est effectivement d'arriver
sur un marché sur lequel il ya beaucoup
de monde en demandant que sur leur site
non
ne pas distribuer en faisant pas de code
donc mises à part les relais presse est
un petit peu difficile pour eux avoir ça
c'est à voir dans leur traque en tout
cas je trouve que le produit sont
accusés est assez cool j'en ai déjà
testé il ya quelques temps j'avais
trouvé ça assez intéressant maintenant à
voir parce qu'il aimait beaucoup de
concurrence et on sait que c'est un
marché qui est très délicat ya des
acteurs qui sont là depuis longtemps et
qui se casse un peu les dents donc avoir
pour un nouvel entrant comme read me
même si derrière on sait qu'un repos et
une grande force de frappe
voilà on reste
prudent et on verra ça part bien
évidemment c'est un produit qu'on a
testé très prochainement dont je vous
invite si c'est pas déjà qu'à vous
abonner comme ça vous serez déjà tout la
cible de remy très clairement un public
assez jeune c'est annoncer clairement
nous parle de photos il nous parle de
design qui est très beau et nous parle
de gainey qui cible un public assez
jeune probablement plus qu'actif design
sympa ils ont fait un produit qui est
assez jolie qui est assez bien fini
c'est pas le truc le plus fou mais en
tout cas c'est pas mal c'est assez bien
fait on en écran 2,6 à 2,3 pouces fhd
plus c'est du lcd une qu'une occupation
de l'écran de 90,8 % vous avez dû
corning gorilla glass 5 à l'avant côté
solidité pour les performances c'est un
instinct dragonne 710 et un processeur
milieu de gamme de chez qualcomm qui
marche parfaitement bien vous en mettez
pas être tranquille là dessus vous avez
soit 4 gigas de ram soit 6 giga de ram
et nous on fait vraiment le focus sur
gaming sur pib j'ai tout ça aussi par
rapport al kini parce que vous avez une
autonomie khedri pour pdg de cette heure
de jeu si vous jouez 7h appelé gène le
soft est franchement un golgoth vous
allez vous faire mal à force mais bon en
termes de performance pour jouer à un
pays b g et à plein de jeux de ce que
vous voulez installer d'autres 710 ça
ira parfaitement bien il ya derrière
d'optimisation logiciel avec de l'hyper
boost 2.0
je ne connaissais pas j'appelle ça le
système blues gaming boost à bousse donc
tout est boosté ça on va les tester donc
je vous dirais effectivement ce que j'en
pense que d'ici quelques jours vous avez
une priori une grosse autonomie d'une
grosse batterie de 4000 45 millions
terreur avec de la recharge rapide c'est
la gooc charge 3.0 assad et quelque
chose vous tiendrons donc on la retrouve
chopo c'est vachement bien en fait ça va
très très vite ça va vous le recharger
en 80 minutes sera changée à 100% de 0 à
100%
et sinon je vais charger à 60% on n'a
pas une trente minutes donc ça aussi
c'est franchement mais ça c'est rapide
côté photo vous avez un double capteur à
l'arrière vous avez un capteur principal
de 16 mégapixels c'est la sony et 1519
ouvre à f
1.7 donc normalement doit être bonne en
qu'on laisse aux tables luminosité lors
ça dépend bien sûr de la caméra
d'ouverture du traitement logiciel de la
puissante banque
c'est pas mal de jeu donc ça aussi on va
se tester et vous avez une deuxième
caméra qui est là pour le mode portrait
les facebook et c'est une 5 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.4 nous annonce de la
photo de nuit de
une qualité en euros donc c'est à dire
la plus haute qualité complice à bord en
photo ça aussi on va tester on verra on
nous annonce une optimisation au niveau
des couleurs avec le cro mag booste ça
également va se tester et également bien
évidemment du hdr du super slow motion
960 images par seconde en 720p salaire
être intéressant je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on utilise trop mais pourquoi pas de
la vidéo en cas de cas je suis pas non
plus surtout soit un truc de fou mais
bon pourquoi pas qui peut le plus peut
le moins et à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 25 méga pixels qui ouvre à f
2.0 et avoir des sept fils groupe pas
mal de petites optimisations logiciel de
ce côté là au niveau de l'ouest c'est un
colorant os 6.0 colorware souhaitons
trouver écoute et le pi propos qui
tourne sur android 9 paille et vous avez
en plus des thèmes propres à remy par
nous ont fait un gros focus 1 au niveau
de la qualité
le smartphone est détesté il est
résistant à l'eau il est résistant aux
chutes
il craint pas tout ce que vous voulez
bon alors on reste quand même prudents
les sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
et c'est un smartphone qui est
disponible dans deux configurations 4
gigas de ram 64 g restockage au prix de
199 euros
et si giga de ram 128 joies de ce sport
128 great de structure j'arrive plus à
parler à 249 euros et qui sera
disponible à partir du 5 juin uniquement
sur le site deux ans et demi je sais pas
comment vous le trouver qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de ce smartphone il vous
botwin au mouvement
quelle couleur c'est un homme qui vous
accroche plus que l'autre est ce que
vous connaissez la marque rémy parce que
ça peut vous tenter est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressante par rapport à la
concurrence qui t'a marqué tout ça en
bas en commentaire et on en reparle dans
quelques jours parce qu'on va se tester
comme ça je pourrais vous dire
exactement ce que j'en pense
donc voilà pour cette présentation 10h30
trois pros je sais pas comment vous
trouvez où est ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant est ce que vous pensez qu
remy a ses chances on s'y prenant comme
ça revendique mois sur son site sans co2
méthane dire tout ça ce que vous en
pensez comme en outre le produit
et puis on en reparle dans quelques
jours je vous donne rendez vous donc dès
demain pourquoi dans notre sujet et
d'ici là son visage vous embrasse tous
[Musique]